please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
well an historic day in American history
yesterday the January 6th Committee of
the House of Representatives
investigating the Trump Riots of 2021
has approved criminal referrals for a
former president no it's not against
Barack Obama come on guys it's against
failed former president Donald Trump NBC
news reports January 6 committee
approves criminal referrals against
Trump for his role in trying to overturn
the 2020 election the panel also issued
a criminal referral to the doj for
conservative Attorney John Eastman he's
the uh genius who came up with the uh
strategy I don't even know what to call
it the idea for how former vice
president Mike Pence could prevent the
certification of the 2020 election we
are going to now hear from one of the
members of the committee Jamie Raskin
let let's listen the first criminal
statute we invoke for referral therefore
is Title 18 section 1512 C which makes
it unlawful for anyone to corruptly
obstruct
influence or impede
any official proceeding of the United
States government
we believe that the evidence described
by my colleagues today and assembled
throughout our hearings warrants a
criminal referral of former president
Donald J Trump John Eastman and others
for violations of this statute wow the
whole purpose and obvious effect of
Trump's scheme were to obstruct
influence and impede this official
proceeding the central moment for the
lawful transfer of power in the United
States
we believe that there is more than
sufficient evidence to refer former
president Donald J Trump John Eastman
and others for violating Title 18
section 371 this statute makes it a
crime to conspire to defraud the United
States
in other words to make an agreement to
impair
obstruct or defeat the lawful functions
of the United States government by
deceitful or dishonest means
former president Trump did not engage in
a plan to defraud the United States
acting alone he entered into agreements
formal and informal with several other
individuals who assisted him with his
criminal objectives I'll say our report
describes in detail the actions of
numerous co-conspirators who agreed with
and participated in Trump's plan to
impair obstruct and defeat the
certification of President Biden's
electoral victory
that said the subcommittee does not
attempt to determine all of the
potential participants in this
conspiracy as our understanding of the
role of many individuals may be
incomplete even today because they
refuse to answer our questions we trust
that the Department of Justice will be
able to form a far more complete picture
through its own investigation
third we make a referral based on Title
18 section
1001 which makes it unlawful to
knowingly and willfully make materially
false statements to the federal
government
just in the interest of time that this
was a very long hearing fourth is
inciting assisting or aiding slash
comforting and Insurrection so four
different criminal referrals how did
Trump react you could probably guess but
we're going to look at that a little
later but let me address some of the
emails that I've received about this
this is a long overdue step
but that's all it is it is one small
step and there's a lot of doubt in
cynicism in the emails that I've been
receiving from many of you over the last
24 hours and I get it I do get it we all
want to see Justice served against these
individuals but it is a process and it's
worth remembering that the doj
has to build the case there is an
astounding amount of evidence they have
to piece that case together and we all
know colloquially and folks everyone is
innocent until proven guilty in a court
of law this show is not a court of law
this is a place where we just speak
frankly we all know as we read through
the different uh statutes that Jamie
Raskin uh described there we all know
Trump did the stuff he's accused of we
all know that colloquially speaking he
did it but the question starts to become
is there the possibility of finding
guilt Beyond A Reasonable Doubt here we
all know and we watched enough to know
that colloquially speaking of course
Donald Trump did the things for which he
is being referred and this includes all
four of those items that Jamie Raskin
mentioned he was able to incite a mob to
storm the capital on January 6th and
attempt to disrupt the peaceful
transition of power and put the lives of
members of Congress and his own vice
president at risk all of it all of it
all of it there are some who will argue
that the criminal referrals that we are
seeing here are strictly a political
move these aren't really law enforcement
elements this is just Democrats playing
politics and it may end up being that if
it doesn't go any further but this is a
necessary step in other words the
committee did what it had to do and it
determined we have the evidence for a
criminal referral it may stop there but
that's all that the the house committee
can actually do now it is a question of
what is Merrick Garland willing to do as
we spoke about yesterday and we talked
about the one word that is the reason
why presidents have not been indicted in
the United States that word is tradition
and that's not a very strong reason not
to indict a president who did things no
other president has done
how could Federal criminal charges
affect Trump's 2024 presidential run
becomes another political question as we
wait for answers to the legal questions
in general
in like a normal World criminal charges
against an individual while they're
running for president would affect their
reputation it would affect their
credibility it would make it more
difficult for them to actually win but
we've already experienced with Donald
Trump in 2016 that seemingly nothing can
actually damage him enough
with the Republican base to torpedo his
presidential campaign 2024 could be
different if Trump were to be convicted
of a crime now we're facing many uh
we're taking many hypothetical steps
into the future he could face prison
time yeah that would make it difficult
to hold office that would make it
difficult to campaign even if he was not
convicted or imprisoned the fact that he
would face criminal charges could be a
liability in a presidential campaign to
the extent that it becomes a distraction
it could raise questions about his
judgment or Fitness for office in a
normal world but this is the Republican
electorate this is the very same
Republican electorate who chose him in
2016 and who gleefully welcomed him back
in 2020 as their nominee so any
assumption that even criminal charges or
a conviction would torpedo Trump's
campaign are possible but potentially
premature until we actually see what
happens let's now talk about Donald
Trump's reaction to this Donald Trump
imploded like a tantruming child pooping
in the sandbox so nobody else can play
in it
over the criminal referrals approved by
the House of Representatives committee
investigating the Trump Riots of January
6 2021. let's go right to the horse's
mouth for lack of a better term Donald
Trump starting with a statement let's
get this right on the screen properly
for you a statement on the January 6th
committee referral
these folks don't get it that when they
come after me people who love freedom
rally around me it strengthens me what
doesn't kill me makes me stronger
Americans know that I pushed for 20 000
troops to prevent violence on January
6th that is a lie first Trump claimed he
wanted 10 000 troops now he says it's
20. there's no evidence that he ever
made that request and that I went on
television and told everyone to go home
he did that hours into the riots and
still said the rioters are Justified for
being there and being angry because the
election was stolen which it wasn't
Trump continuing think of it
the radical left Democrats communists
spied on my campaign that's a lie lied
to the fisa court that's a lie lied to
Congress many people have lied to
Congress it doesn't actually change the
reality of this and and of course when
Trump's people lied to Congress they all
said lying to Congress is no big deal
allowed an invasion of our country on
the southern border
policy has not substantively changed
since Trump under Biden on the border
embarrassed Us in Afghanistan Biden did
the same thing Trump said he was going
to do gave away our energy Independence
we actually are more over producing
under Biden in terms of oil than we were
under Trump killed us on job losing
regulations meaningless and vague
wouldn't use the ten thousand plus
soldiers I recommended for January 6th
in his last truth he said it was twenty
thousand truth the number changes uh
refused to look into election fraud the
reason for January 6th rigged and stole
the 2020 election allowed ballot
stuffing FBI Facebook Twitter and Biden
crime that's just a mess that's just a
word salad and he continues continued
from previous truth and I'm the one that
the corrupt and partisan unselect
committee goes after a two-tiered quote
justice system and by the way
whatever happened with the massive
number of crimes committed by Joe and
Hunter Biden were unaware of any such
crimes as of right now they're right
there documented and 100 certain also
where's the prosecutor from Delaware
what happened to him is he friends with
the Ukrainian prosecutor who didn't
prosecute after Biden held up the
billion dollar payment to Ukraine I did
nothing wrong in all caps as you see
he's losing it then he starts retweeting
various videos propaganda videos
including one that refers to Adam's
Shifty shift
uh retweets a message from Elise
stefanic
posts a poll a video of Alan dershowitz
another video of Alan dershowitz
promotes Troth sensual
and then is just posting stuff on and on
and on and then picks it back up again
this morning with almost no delay files
conclusively revealed that the FBI
totally discredited damning and by the
way he spells damning the way a beaver
does you know beavers are damning stuff
it's just beyond parody
uh damning factual information from
Hunter Biden's laptop from hell it's
just on and on here it's only even
tangential and then he goes full
conspiracy
the so-called deep State often referred
to by many other names including
cheaters insurrectionists Communists and
yes even our good old rhinos have been
working on Sinister and evil plots for a
long time even well before I came to
office they are long-seeded swamp
creatures and are bad news for the USA
blah blah blah blah blah he then goes
after the committee that sent the
referrals I see where the unselect
committee using the Democrats favorite
weapon disinformation is trying to make
the case that I didn't really believe I
won the election that's a total lie I
never thought for even a moment that the
presidential election of 2020 was not
rigged and stolen and my conviction
became even stronger as time went by now
with all of the massive evidence that
has come to light including recently
with the FBI suppression of election
changing information I was 100 right
hours hours on Truth social truth
essential spreading lies and being
triggered now at the end of the day the
next step is up to the Department of
Justice is the Department of Justice is
Merritt Garland ready and willing to do
what we all know is supported by the
facts and that is what that is to charge
Donald Trump do I believe he will spend
a day in prison I still do not
but do I believe it would be the correct
thing to charge him I would because
that's a decision you make based on the
evidence let me know if you expect
charges against Donald Trump Friday
December 23rd we are doing our final
membership special of the Year
everyone's first month's payment will be
donated by us to an organization that
sends cash to people who really need it
and it will be doubled so hypothetical
okay memberships are six bucks a month
Friday we get you a coupon code saves
you fifty percent you pay three bucks we
donate the three bucks you still keep
the membership and we double the three
dollars with six we match the first
fifteen thousand dollars we've never
done this before
I want you to participate I want you to
be involved all you have to do is get on
my mailing list by signing up at
davidpackman.com the box to enter your
email is at the top right of the website
more on Friday very exciting quick break
be right back
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at givedirectly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
some someone living on a dollar or two a
day help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by December Thirty One and your
donation will be doubled go to give
directly.org Pacman the link is down
below I want to talk today about the
scam of modern conservatism and how the
right is manipulating and exploiting
people with an ideology that exists only
in theory and in reality is completely
different from that which it claims to
be let me explain modern conservatism is
a political ideology that claims to be
about limited government
individual liberty and responsibility
Traditional Values Freedom not
regulating businesses on and on and on
and there's two parts of this the first
part is that in theory all of that
sounds really appealing it's sort of
like hey doesn't pay no taxes sound
appealing in some general sense I mean
yeah I'd love to keep every dollar that
I gross and not pay any taxes in some
general sense that sounds pretty good it
sounds appealing in certain contexts the
ideas espoused by conservatism
sound uh beneficial but in practice
modern conservatism has become a scam
that is used to manipulate and exploit
people and its values are just as
quickly abandoned by those espousing
them once they are no longer convenient
or productive or helping their cause
let's talk about some examples one way
that modern conservatism is being used
to manipulate the public is through
propaganda and misinformation
conservative media outlets and
politicians will often spread misleading
information
based on their supposed principles in
order to win elections at the end of the
day all they care about is winning
elections and this includes conspiracy
theories when it's convenient
cherry picking data using completely
loaded language to evoke an emotional
response we are pro-life
wow everybody else must be against life
that sounds pretty bad we're for tax
relief
wow taxes must just simply be oppressive
taxes must be like slavery which is
quite literally what some Libertarians
say and by using this language and
manipulating The public's understanding
of the facts conservatives shape public
opinion and influence policy decisions
and voters in their favor in ways that
are completely misleading and don't
actually benefit the people that end up
voting for them and that's a big part of
the scam and we're going to get back to
that
another way that the public is exploited
by the scam of conservatism is through
dog whistle politics so this is when
they use coded language that certain
groups of people understand to have a
specific meaning like for example when
they say family values
I mean that sounds pretty good right
like families are good and values that
support families that all sounds good
but it's a signal to conservative voters
you're supposed to be opposed to
same-sex marriage you're supposed to be
opposed to abortion more recently you're
supposed to be opposed to even
fundamental just basic trans rights they
don't say it outright and this allows
the right-wing politicians to appeal to
certain groups of Voters without
alienating others it allows them to
avoid accountability and it allows
something that Donald Trump actually did
very well which is you kind of take
every position on issues and even if you
don't overtly do it you leave enough
vagaries that anybody could sort of
stumble across some version of a
position that they agree with you or at
least don't overtly disagree modern
conservatism also exploits the public
through policy and this is maybe the
most important thing
right wing conservative whatever word
you want to use for it policy
disproportionately benefits the wealthy
the powerful and those with what we
might call like standard or agent
identities in American society and
conservatives will argue lower taxes are
good for everybody increases economic
growth increases Prosperity Rising tide
lifts all boats they'll say it with
regulation reducing regulation is good
for everybody economic growth prosperity
it's great the truth is it's a scam
those very policies they they do
particularly in the short term increase
profits for corporations in the wealthy
but they externalize the burden of the
pollution that is created or the low
wages that are paid which then we all
have our taxes go to social welfare
programs to support people who rightly
need those programs because the
corporations are paying low wages they
claim it's good for everybody their
economic policy is good for everybody
but it leads to cuts and social services
or increased spending on Social Services
higher health care costs lower wages for
workers we all pay for it we are getting
scammed by it so modern conservatism is
a scam that by scamming the public and
exploiting the public through all of the
things I mentioned
disproportionately benefits the elites
they love to say Democrats are all about
this elitist cabal that's that's all
they care about it's actually
conservatism that is doing that a couple
modern examples we can look at how
right-wingers sought to undermine the
legitimate legitimacy of the 2020
presidential election there was no
evidence of widespread voter fraud that
impacted the results they scammed their
supporters they raised money Trump did
claiming we're going to use the money to
flip the election he kept the money used
it to pay off campaign debt total and
complete scam we've seen these
conspiracies promoted by conservative
media outlets and by politicians by
Trump himself and that is the
prototypical example of how conservatism
is used to make the public think a
certain thing
and then get them to take an action
either going to the Capitol donating
money whatever the case may be uh we
have also seen by the way this very same
rhetoric used in order to get the public
to support ideas that are seemingly
completely antithetical to the values of
the right
for example
free speech for all including for
businesses until we no longer like the
speech and moderation rules that are
being applied on Twitter or Facebook or
whatever and all of a sudden Freedom
Liberty and Low regulation goes out the
window and it's we must Force Facebook
to publish our covet disinformation we
must Force Twitter to publish the
pictures of Hunter Biden's genitalia
they abandoned those principles right
away and the voters at the end of the
day are just getting scammed they don't
know up down left right they don't know
what's going on last thing on this when
you
Wonder
what is the end game with any of these
supposedly conservative policy ideas
whether it's the immigration reform
ideas they have taxation whatever the
case may be understand that the end goal
is to reinforce and perpetuate
the rich and corporations maintaining
power and profitability that is the big
scam that they claim their entire
movement is a set of policies that helps
everyone
and it doesn't and we've talked before
about how that that is that is not
completely missing from the Democratic
party but the degree to which it exists
in the modern right-wing movement is
completely stunning it is a scam last
week uh we spoke about what it is about
people who are victimized by scams that
keeps them being victimized and part of
it is is the cult aspect and part of it
is psychological factors we looked at
the people being scammed now we've
looked at what the scam is
and it would be great if people would
figure this out and stop falling for it
but it actually is a party that depends
on people continuing to fall for it
um we now have reached a horrible
milestone in the United States where
guns are the leading cause of child
deaths for those under 18. the New York
Times had a very good piece on this a
couple of days ago and if you look at
leading causes of death for children
ages 1 through 18 if you're looking on
the screen you see this green line which
is guns which has now surpassed motor
vehicle crashes at 19 of deaths for
children age 1 to 18 it is guns followed
by motor vehicle crashes cancer drug
overdoses which has increased and
Suffocation has decreased putting it
into fifth position into fifth position
this Century okay since the year 2000 as
you can see on the screen if you're
looking guns have have risen as the
cause of death from 10 percent of kids
age 1 to 18 to 19 percent
nearly five in a hundred thousand die
each year kids
uh these are stunning numbers most of
the deaths are homicides many of the
victims are black and mostly boys there
are also suicides the suicides are
mostly white and mostly boys there are
relatively few of what would be called
accidental deaths we take issue with the
term accidental typically you're talking
about negligence actually but very few
are what are often called accidental
deaths we hear about oh a dad was
cleaning his gun and shot his daughter
dead we do see those stories but those
are actually relatively few this is a
uniquely American problem and in order
to start thinking about Solutions we
have to really understand the problem
this is not a global epidemic if you
look globally the most common causes of
death for children are infectious
diseases 45 disproportionately in the
developing world
uh 15 uh pneumonia and respiratory
disease 12 preterm birth and neonatal
disorders ten percent diarrheal
categorized disease nine percent
congenital defects now as a math issue
it is true I know people are going to
write to me and say this so I will be
very upfront with you if you reduce one
thing simply by comparison another thing
is going to go up so in the U.S
we have certainly reduced some of these
elements as causes of death right
diarrheal disease death in the United
States and kids is a lot rarer than in
other parts of the country so if you
drop that then other stuff will go up
like gun deaths but even in the rest of
the developed world where there isn't
much diarrheal child death you do not
see gun death numbers like we see in the
United States so what are the
differences between the Us and other
countries well
we have one of the highest rates of gun
ownership is it that alone no but that's
a factor one of the highest rates of gun
ownership so there are guns around kids
we have a lack of strict gun control
laws in most States
we have a culture that glorifies
violence and uh exposes even kids I mean
you know we're talking 14 15 16 17 year
olds completely exposed and affected by
that very culture that glorifies
violence sees guns as a way to solve
problems High rate of poverty
High rate of income inequality both of
which have been studied in connection to
guns as a public health issue and lack
of access to Mental Health Resources now
of course I have no interest
in ignoring any of these aspects the
right loves to say it's just mental
health meanwhile they don't want to fund
Mental Health mental health is certainly
a factor but availability of guns
widespread nature of guns that's a
factor as well there are clear steps we
can take I've outlined so many of them
so many times before no one step will
solve this problem no one step will
solve the problem and we always hear
after a shooting well you know your idea
of limiting clip capacity wouldn't have
prevented this particular shooting
I don't know anyone who claims any one
thing when you have a problem that's
based on six to eight things there's no
one thing that will solve that problem
but we have to work on all of these
things and quite frankly the numbers
speak from the for themselves unique to
the United States if you want to let me
put it this way
if you want to find other countries with
a gun violence uh problem affecting kids
to the degree that we have in the United
States
I'm not going to name the countries you
will find countries that none of these
right-wingers would say are in any way
equivalent to the United States
so take a look
we're going to link to the study in the
New York Times we're going to continue
talking about all of it but we have
plenty of ideas
but we have a right wing that is
unwilling to actually try any of them
make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel youtube.com slash the
David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today billshare contributor to
the Washington monthly Politico and Real
Clear Politics also host of The History
Podcast when America worked Bill always
great to have you on and we're welcoming
your dog today as well yes if you can
see in the corner here Nova is chewing
on some plastic yes hopefully they'll
hopefully they'll keep her occupied
let's hope so
um so let's let's just start with the
outlook for the next two years I mean uh
interesting Wall Street Journal op-ed
yesterday about Republicans uh being too
dimwitted to really wield the power that
they're going to have and how they're
fighting over McCarthy and it's just
kind of becoming a mess of course
Republicans will narrowly control the
house they will not control the Senate
it looked like the Senate would be 51-49
and it sort of is although Kirsten
Cinema now says she's going to be an
independent but seemingly will not
dramatically change how she plans to
vote I think maybe although I'm not
completely sure about that so like what
is anything going to happen in the next
two years legislatively that is
significant I mean you know me David I'm
a fairly optimistic person but uh you
know you know I'm saying my expectations
very very low for this Congress I mean
if they can keep the lights on and if
we're a debt default you know
congratulations yeah this still works
um if there is a utility for 24 for each
party from what does or doesn't happen
over the next two years it seems clear
that Republicans are going to want to
make the case in 24 that repo that
Democrats didn't get anything done in
this two-year period and that things got
worse that may be by their own doing of
course as often is in politics is that
the type of thing that is likely to
swing a presidential election like the
one we would see in 24 a sort of
referendum on what Democrats got done
when they held one of two houses and had
Joe Biden in the white house or is that
just not likely to be a very impactful
um argument uh two years 23 months from
now well generally speaking you know
assuming Biden runs is the nominee yes
uh you would assume that 2024 would be a
referendum on him I mean that's
typically how re-elections go and
something that I talked about over the
course of the past year midterms are not
really referendums on the president
that's a bit of a misnomer uh and uh and
I think that has been borne out in this
pastor because the new Biden's approval
was not good
uh but you know midterms
uh I mean this is not you know a settled
argument but there is an argument that I
I've embraced that they're about balance
and an electorate trying to balance
things out from the past selection kind
of keep things roughly in the middle uh
which is why the opposition probably
tends to do well
irrespective of presidential approval uh
and that didn't happen this time
I would argue because the balancing
Choice was the Democrats because
Republicans put up candidates who were
essentially imbalanced and were doing
disruptive things and that spooked that
spooked much of the electorate uh and it
speaks to a uh an intra-party conflict
with Republicans Mitch McConnell whom
Democrats looked at as you know
obstructionist extraordinaire
had a different take on how to handle
Joe Biden in the past two years which
was let's have a modicum of cooperation
let's I hate shutdown shutdowns always
make us look bad let's let's do the bare
minimum let's do the infrastructure
let's do the semiconductor Investments
to compete with China let's partner on
Ukraine and we can fight Democrats on a
bunch of other things where we think
they're going too far to the left
and the Trump forces didn't subscribe to
that they were mad at McConnell for
being as Cooperative as he was they put
up a slightest set of candidates who
were totally out to lunch who were
caught up on Election denial and other
culture War type things and that gave
room for the Democrats to say look we're
trying to keep things on the on the
street and narrow here uh and these
people want to you know uh you know
break all the China uh so now you're
going into a congress where again you
know Mitch McConnell can't dictate what
the party strategy is because you have
this narrowly controlled house uh
although I should I should caveat here
we don't even know what the speaker's
going to be correct uh so you know if
it's McCarthy Kevin McCarthy and if
Kevin McCarthy is beholden to the far
right then you have this open question
can you keep the lights on can you avoid
a government shutdown can't you raise a
debt limit to avoid a global economic
destroying debt default that becomes a
big unknown uh if the anti-mccarthy
faction makes it impossible for
MacArthur to get the 218 he needs
there's this threat from the moderate
Splinter faction of the Republican Party
led by you know Don Bacon at least Don
Bacon's been the one who's been most
vocal about this saying if these guys
push push us too far we'll partner with
Democrats and put up a bipartisan
speaker be a Republican
but someone who's not beholden to the
far far right and if that's the case
then maybe we're working for business
then maybe we actually can pass a few
things and maybe makana would be willing
to do some bare minimum stuff again so
Republicans don't seem like they're
insane
on the uh Kirsten Cinema situation
um there's basically every analysis
under under the sun this was done and
timed in a way just to upset Democrats
which doesn't seem to I mean it seems
strategically like it leaves a little
something to be desired in terms of an
explanation there's the Arizona
explanation which is Cinema was facing
um a challenge from a progressive
Democrat by becoming an independent
she's able to short-circuit that
possibility and maybe uh turn it into a
three-way race in which the incumbent
independent easily wins re-election in
Arizona that that's another possibility
three is she just really wants attention
and when it's 51 to 49 the way to get
attention back is to at least threaten
that maybe it's actually 50 50 again
what what's your best assessment of the
timing and the decision
uh you know I'm someone who has uh
defended Cinema over the course of the
past years she's arguably the most
effective legislature the Democrats have
had I know the the counter argument is
well she you know kneecapped their dream
agenda so don't give her credit for
passing something smaller uh but part of
that argument was that it was impossible
to get the 60 on things you could
McConnell wouldn't let you get the 60 on
infrastructure or gun safety or the
Electoral account act or what have you
and that proved not to be true Cinema
was the person uh doing those deals
actually doing the negotiations and
finding the common ground so I think she
deserves credit for that uh and I think
she has taken away the wrong lesson
from that experience uh she was able to
do what she did because she could Bank
on 50 Democrats right for whatever
compromise she hashed out because there
was an intrinsic you know I mean you
know parties tend to be favorable to
their incumbents uh assuming they're
going to be the nominees that Arizona's
a closely divided State you can't a
Democrat can't guarantee to win a
Statewide election there uh if she is
your best bet you you will go along with
her on her deals in hopes that she keep
keeps that seat for Democrats now
maybe she's not me she she won't be the
Democratic nominee uh maybe Democrats
can put up a nominee that can be
competitive in a three or three-way race
and so it puts Democrats in an awkward
position with her and so her deals I
mean the Challenger before was
convincing ten Republicans this is in
your interest you know it is better for
you to do this infrastructure deal or do
this gun safety deal then it is not we I
know we're going to fight on Election
Day but you'll be in a worse position if
you fight me on this which is hard
enough but she did that now she has to
fight a two-front war
to pass any kind of deal and mind you we
even know what kind of situation the
house is going to be in if it's going to
be hospitable to Deals her political
value is I'm the person that gets things
done if she's no longer that person
then she has a harder argument to make
and and so I I if I was advising her a
month ago I'd say you know what why
don't you wait and see what happens with
the speaker's race right why don't you
wait and see if you can get a couple
more deals under your belt for luxury
why don't you do a little Outreach to
the Democrats in Arizona and say hey
look this is where my thinking's at I
mean there are other Democrats that
break ranks from time to time and to
have nearly as much uh upset with the
base as soon as Arizona because she
hasn't done that Outreach and and so I
hate to play you know armchairs
psychologists with this stuff
but you look at the recent uh reporting
that the Washington Post did on this
which suggests that this was sort of in
the making for a long time uh and I just
kind of come down to I just think she'd
I don't want the attention argument
because
she doesn't do a lot of media I think
she does a lot of things that don't
attract attention uh but I do think she
likes being a party of one she likes
following her own Compass she doesn't
like having to play the footsie with the
elements in the basement don't get what
she's doing and so she made a decision
that's comfortable for her but I don't
necessarily think is the right strategy
both legislatively and politically I am
no Cinema fan by by any means but I do
find interesting that for a while now
there have been a lot of people saying
Cinema shouldn't be in the Democratic
party because she's not really a
Democrat you hear sometimes the same the
same thing about Joe manchin the people
who didn't want her to be a Democrat
have sort of won in the sense that now
she isn't a Democrat but now they're
still mad and there's some there's like
something interesting about that but as
I've said before you know when people
talk about you got a primary Joe manchin
with a progressive if a progressive
defeats Joe manchin in a primary in West
Virginia
I don't see any way that that
Progressive wins I think that that seat
becomes a republican seat Arizona's
Dynamics are different than West
Virginia and an actual bona fide
three-way race is a very different
situation than Mansion being primaried
by a progressive but there is some state
level strategy here that is at least a
little more connected to reality than
the West Virginia Mansion thing it seems
to me well I I
yeah yes yes and no I mean obviously
Arizona's not as red as West Virginia is
yeah uh now progressives have challenged
mansion and primaries Mansion stops them
yes goes on the win
um look Arizona
if it's blue it is just barely blue
uh even this past election look them
Democrats managed to win governor and
Senate but not house right uh the house
popular vote was Republican and even if
you make some s because there are a
couple of uncontested races even you use
some estimates there Republicans would
still have an edge in the popular vote
you know Republicans put up truly insane
candidates for a swing state and got
burned if they learned their lesson and
put up you know center-right candidates
you can't count on any old Democrat
holding on to any seat in Arizona uh so
the notion that I mean yes Cinemas
numbers are bad
and I think she did things
that I I think her issue set is
perfectly fine for Arizona I think her
legitimate success is excellent for
Arizona I think the optic she's chosen
to do along with that have been terrible
and somewhat self-sabotaging uh and so
it puts her in a precarious position but
if you get Ruben Gallego or Greg Stanton
uh uh and that person can get you know
30 I mean a three race is just such a
jump ball yeah because you have no idea
first you have no idea are you going to
carry a lake or a Doug deucey type on
the Republican side that's a huge
difference uh and we really don't know
you can't look at a poll today and
really know how much the cinema pull
from the Republic from the center right
in the center left uh I mean I wouldn't
be optimistic about it to be honest
because you look at the raises where
Independents have won uh
typically speaking one Party's candidate
just tanks right making it easily
independent to pick up the line share of
of one party's votes there are a couple
of ones I'm aware of where an
independent one with credible Republican
Democratic candidates uh one is Angus
King in May when he when he ran uh and
he won that Governor's race by a hair uh
and then when he ran for Senate it was
much easier for him but he just but
you're talking getting in the upper 30s
to win that kind of race the other one
is Jesse Ventura governor of Minnesota
when I know a little bit more about the
fascinating about the the Jesse Ventura
race is the main reason why he won was
same-day registration right 70 of his
vote was same day registrates and who
were they 20 something white male
wrestling fans like it's not a it's not
a typical kind of race that you can
model anything else after so you know
Cinema is is a decent credit case
because she's an incumbent
uh and I'm not saying she can't pull it
off but it's a real roll of the dice uh
and I I would say I think you could do
better mending some fences with your
Democratic base so you can win that
primary it's very unusual to lose a
primer if you're a synonym coming so I
think with a little little elbow grease
she could have done that uh it made her
life easier but obviously she made her
choices well I don't really make
predictions but I will predict that uh
Cinemas fate will not be to be in Baja
California off the grid surfing and
doing conspiracy theories Like Jesse
Ventura ended up after his uh
gubernatorial run uh Bill share
contributor to Washington monthly
Politico real clear politics and also
host of The History Podcast when America
worked Bill always a pleasure having you
on all right same here take care happy
holidays
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show an
incoming Republican Congressman promoted
very strongly by Arbiter of ideas Glenn
Greenwald appears to have made up
essentially his entire backstory of his
life this is quite a story a Business
Insider reports incoming Republican
Congressman George Santos reportedly
lied about his employment history where
he went to college losing four employees
at the Pulse Nightclub shooting and
possibly even his residence an incoming
Republican congressman from Long Island
has several gaps in his resume according
to a New York Times report he appears to
have lied about all of the things that I
just mentioned and claimed to have lost
four employees in the 2016 Pulse
Nightclub shooting
oh boy the investigation found the
following first his description of his
employment doesn't add up his biography
says he worked at Goldman Sachs but
spokeswoman Abby Collins says there's no
record that he ever worked there he said
he was an associate asset manager at
Citigroup but spokeswoman there said it
can't confirm he ever worked there and
that they haven't had an asset
management Operations Division since
2005 which is five years before he
claims to have graduated college
the times found no IRS record of a
charity uh he says he owns friends of
pets United and the beneficiary of a
2017 fundraiser by the group says they
never got any of the money that he
supposedly raised for them oh boy
secondly he's reportedly faced numerous
evictions claimed to be a landlord and
may not actually live at his current
address he claimed to be a landlord last
year but didn't list any properties
he was evicted in 2017 from a residence
after owing more than ten thousand
dollars in unpaid rent
then we get to his educational history
man I should just make up a much more
interesting background it just seems you
could just make it up his higher
education history appears to be a lie he
said he graduated with a degree in econ
and finance from Baroque College in New
York City in 2010 representatives from
the school said they have no record he
was ever enrolled there despite
searching variations of his name
a biography on the national RNC
Republican Campaign Committee website
says he went to NYU a spokesman there
says they have no record he ever went
there either
fourth there's a mystery as to where his
money comes from and fifth he claimed to
have lost four employees in the 2016
Pulse Nightclub shooting a review was
done none of the 49 victims seemed to
have any association with any of the
organizations that he even claims to be
associated with Glenn Greenwald posted
uh in mid-november Meet George Santos
the first ever Brazilian American and
first ever openly gay Republican elected
to congress in U.S history the son of
working class immigrant parents who left
Brazil for the U.S he was born and
raised in Jackson Heights Queens looks
like that didn't work particularly well
you know I've wondered before when
people just like make up a backstory
they make up where they went to school
or whatever
why are they doing it given that it is
it seems so likely you will eventually
get caught particularly in a high
profile and public circumstance such as
this one sometimes it's this is a way to
advance my career
or to gain social status I can claim to
be more qualified I can claim to be more
accomplished I'll be more likely to be
hired for a job or promoted or accepted
socially or may be more likely to win an
election sometimes people will lie about
their credentials out of desperation
it's a desperate situation they feel I'm
genuinely not qualified for anything I
need this opportunity so I'm gonna lie
to get ahead
interestingly some individuals are just
dishonest by Nature they're just willing
to lie no matter what regardless of the
consequences this is what we sometimes
colloquially call pathological lies and
I've known people like this people who
just lie all the time for no obvious
reason they just lie they always lie and
uh we don't know which of these applies
to George Santos but it is not going
particularly well by the way I mentioned
he's openly gay there are some who are
reacting to this with homophobia
where it's
it's the right Wingers who are saying
you know we shouldn't have gone with a
gay guy this is the problem when you go
with a gay guy I'm not aware of any
evidence that links gay people to
dishonesty he just seems to be a
dishonest clown will there be any
repercussions uh probably not quite
frankly
former Donald Trump propagandist Stephen
Bannon is desperate desperate for Trump
to stop with the nft digital trading
cards and there are actually slightly
more and more voices that are saying ah
some of this stuff is not going going
particularly well here is some kind of
Round Table I think this was at America
Fest and Steve Bannon is just not happy
with the Trump nft grift and I
understand that it's really it's really
cringy I have a my pillow
[Applause]
I tell everyone
thank you God bless you thank you if we
give the president a promo code can you
stop with the nfts I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding the nfts that sold out in
12 hours Steve's just jealous over here
yeah yeah I know that's a free and fair
market just yeah I mean listen Bannon
knows the entire Trump nft thing is a
complete and total grift and scam and
you can just tell he can't get away from
the humiliation of that we played a clip
yesterday of him saying whoever came up
with this idea should be fired and it is
very interesting in the sense that some
of the most reliable historically
reliable and stalwart Trump supporters
the confidants the Loyalists they are
now mocking Trump pretty regularly and
part of this maybe is the polling that
they're seeing maybe to some degree the
writing is on the wall here's another
example by the way here's a clip of Matt
Gates that I believe it's the exact same
event
uh saying that on the issue of who
should be speaker Donald Trump is wrong
and Gates is not the type of guy who
would typically uh distance himself or
Draw distinctions with Trump a couple of
unpleasant facts let's get him on the
table number one president Trump has
said the other day the New York Times
broke that he was whipping votes for
Kevin McCarthy and then president Trump
gave the great Matt Boyle at Breitbart
an exclusive interview and he said hey I
think Kevin's earned it president Trump
president president Trump is both
whipped votes here and he's come out and
told Breitbart and Matt Boyle that he's
actually supporting Kevin
what about this is the Trump Posse right
here I can't wait to vote for Donald
Trump in the 2024 election but if Donald
Trump believes that Kevin McCarthy
should be speaker of the house then
Donald Trump is wrong and Donald Trump
has not always nailed it on the HR front
I remember having to fight against Jeff
sessions and Mattis and Rex Tillerson so
president Trump is the leader of our
movement he sets the vision but Donald
Trump has not moved a single vote when
it comes to the people considering how
to cast their lot in the speaker's race
wow so not only think about that not
only is Gates saying he disagrees with
Trump about who should be speaker of the
house when Republicans take over in
January he's saying Trump isn't even
influencing even a single person in the
House of Representatives to reconsider
or change how they are going to vote
that's a pretty serious attack from a
guy who has been a trump brown-noser for
years at this point in time and of
course we'll eventually know the answer
but the hypothetical is the supposition
the question is this a sign that the
tide is turning the polling is sort of
suggesting that and hearing from people
like Bannon and Gates suggests that that
also may be the way it is we'll know
more I believe
by something like April 1st I think it
will be pretty clear another really
interesting thing that's that's going on
is an intramaga Civil War let's talk
about that next
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
are now at War and it is getting
delightfully ugly and we should all
cheer this on because the more fractured
that Mega trumpism is the worse it is
for the Republican Party HuffPost
reporting Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert get personal in a very
public spat the extremist congresswoman
from Georgia accused her Colorado
counterpart of quote High School drama
writes Josephine Harvey for HuffPost
what is this all about this started
because bobert criticized green at the
America Fest event
for backing House minority leader Kevin
McCarthy for speaker this I believe is
the moment that started this hilarious
fight someone who we all respect
Marjorie Taylor green says Kevin
McCarthy is going to be a great speaker
I
I guess you'll have to ask Marjorie
about that I'm a fan of hers I'm an
admirer but it's not something we see
the same Lauren well you know I I've
been aligned with Marjorie and accused
of believing a lot of the things that
she believes in I don't believe in this
just like um I don't believe in Russian
space places are you a hard no space
lasers and all of this no I'm just
saying we need to actually have an
inside conversation and and make sure
that these promises are there wow
so subsequent to this Marjorie Taylor
green took to Twitter to respond where
she put out a three-tweet screed
starting with quote I've supported and
donated to Lauren bobert
president Trump has supported and
donated to Lauren bobert Kevin McCarthy
has supported and donated to Lauren
bobert she just barely came through by
500 votes so the argument there is
despite all of our powerful support she
barely won
second
quote she gladly takes our money but
when she's been asked Lauren refuses to
endorse president Trump she refuses to
support Kevin McCarthy and she
childishly threw me under the bus for a
cheap sound bite Marjorie Taylor green
continuing quote the country is facing
extremely difficult times
Americans expect conservative Fighters
like us to work together to save America
and that is the only Mission I'm 100
percent devoted to not High School drama
and media sound bites save America
defeat the Democrats
um this is super interesting because
we've known about the wings of the
Republican Party the pro-trump and the
anti-trump wing we know about how Mitt
Romney and Adam kinzinger and Liz Cheney
are in a different wing of the
Republican party than the Maga people
these are all Maga people this is now a
subsequent division within Maga trumpism
where you have the pro Kevin McCarthy
people and the anti-keven McCarthy
people there are a bunch of different
reasons for this one of those reasons
has been McCarthy's
less than total enthusiasm for some of
the tactics
that Trump wanted to use to try to steal
an election he didn't win in 2020. so
this is a division we should absolutely
be encouraging this can only be bad for
Trump and for Republicans as the 2024
primary gets going green and bobert two
of the most visible prominent newish
trumpist figures and for them to be
going at it is extraordinarily
interesting and potentially beneficial
to the left we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to David P this
caller has a really interesting question
do these Mega people genuinely not
understand what Free Speech means or are
they only pretending
take this question why does the right
seem to always complain about Free
Speech when they're talking about
private companies are they intentionally
saying that because they know that Their
audience doesn't really know what Free
Speech actually is right or they
themselves don't know what it means yeah
it could be either one this is a really
great question so often
these right Wingers will say this is an
issue of the First Amendment even if it
did you see that thing pop up I don't
know if that was just on screen a little
clip related to one of my cables just
literally popped up like like a uh like
like a jumping bean of some kind I
wonder if the video caught that we'll
have to review the footage later
um two different parts here one they
often say there's a First Amendment
issue when it has nothing to do with the
government the government and the First
Amendment related Twitter doing
something not related to the First
Amendment secondly do they know the
difference between Free Speech or
um moderation it's not clear that they
do I genuinely don't know the answer
there are some slightly more informed
right-wingers
who understand the difference between
free speech and First Amendment and just
moderation but they will say platforms
like Twitter and Facebook have become so
large that they are essentially like a
town square and they should be regulated
as if they were government entities
interestingly that's pretty heavy-handed
from the regulation perspective
so at the end of the day I don't know
what right-wingers do and don't know are
they ignorant are they arguing in bad
faith is it some combination of the two
you be the judge we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the Elon Musk Twitter CEO situation
we're going to talk about Madison
cawthorne being sued by his own lawyers
for not paying them seems like that's
going around in trumpism and we will
talk about Alex Jones salary request as
part of his bankruptcy proceedings wild
wacky request sign up at
joinpakman.com get instant access to the
world famous and award-winning bonus
show
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below